cnn is still trying to sort through this
joe rogan situation and they put out a
tweet yesterday
says joe rogan is one of the most
popular podcast hosts in the world
despite a series of controversies cnn
business spoke with a researcher who has
studied his appeal to explain why his
audience loves him
and so they've brought in a researcher
to figure out why do people like joe
rogan so much and here's what they came
up with watch this
the joe rogan experience joe rogan hosts
one of the most popular podcasts in the
world i'm not an anti-vaxx person right
but despite his claims he's used his
platform to make false and inaccurate
statements about covet 19 in vaccines if
you're a healthy person and you're
exercising all the time and you're young
and you're eating well and like i don't
think you need to worry about this he's
also used racist and offensive language
we get out and we're giggling oh you see
plenty of names we walk into planet of
the apes
we walked into africa dude even with
these controversies rogan remains wildly
popular so the question is
why
i've probably spent hundreds of hours
listening to joe rogan yeah no easily
hundreds of hours gabriel wisniewski
parks is a research fellow at unc
greensboro who has studied rogan's
appeal what makes him so magnetic to his
audience is his very vocal resistance to
tribalism this is somebody who can have
on his podcast ben shapiro and alex
jones and have deep and interesting
meaningful conversations with them and
then in the one other breath he can have
on cornell west and bernie sanders and
do the exact same thing and this really
resonates with people and one other
connection we can make that i don't
think should be overestimated is joe
rogan's background as a stand-up
comedian this archetype of the comedian
as the truth-teller
of course they had to bring this dork in
there to uh research and find out
because cnn is they are they are
absolutely stumped
um
they don't understand how to get people
to watch things obviously you know
because they only have five viewers and
so they're looking at joe rogan and uh
obvio we know there's a lot of a lot of
envy that plays into it
but they also are sort of interested
from a scientific perspective
how does this guy do do this
and so they have to bring in a joe rogan
researcher to tell them
and what are his findings well um he's
funny people like funny things
and people like comedians you know they
like to laugh
so we needed a phd candidate
you know we needed to bring him in he
needed to spend hundreds of hours
researching
i would love by the way to be a fly on
the wall uh watching as
that researcher
is you know listening to joe rogan
subjecting himself into it to it in
order to research it
just crying probably sobbing
uncontrollably at everything that he's
hearing that would be fantastic
um but after all of his research they
he's discovered that people like to
laugh
wow
and also
people like to hear you know different
interesting conversations and they like
to hear from different sorts of people
you know i could have told you that
without listening to any joe rogan at
all
and whatever you're paying your rogan
researcher i i'll you could pay me half
of that
and i'll listen to joe rogan's podcast
and give you similar insights
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated